foreign
[Music]
and welcome back to Rotten Tomatoes is
wrong the weekly podcast where we take a
movie and we say well wait Rotten
Tomatoes did they really get that right
as far as the Tomato Meter goes the
Tomato Meter is the amalgam of all the
critics and what they thought about a
particular film and so if it's 60 or
above that means it's fresh
unfortunately a lot of times the movies
that we love and there's a whole book
about it as a matter of fact called the
rotten movies we love they fall south of
that number and we say wait a minute
Rotten Tomatoes is wrong about that
sometimes the Tomato Meter loves a movie
that you or I or your mom or your uncle
are like wait wait that movie's not that
good so it's a whole fun reason for
debate and that's why we have this
podcast we've been going over 100
episodes strong with me and my co-host
Jacqueline Coley who is out on
assignment today globetrotting around
the world doing fancy schmancy
interviews at film festivals sipping on
Dom perignonji works very hard too and
we are welcoming a new team member uh
Glenn is here now as well as Brian
engineering because producing Lucy is on
maternity leave she had her kid uh we're
very happy for uh producing Lucy and her
new bundle of joy so congratulations
there and this is all just a nice sort
of Preamble behind the scenes because
the movie We're actually talking about
today boy it will get under your skin
and it won't leave some 25 years later
it is Event Horizon from
1997 directed by Paul Anderson my Paul
Anderson most people would say that Paul
Thomas Anderson is their Paul Anderson
but my Paul Anderson is Paul W S
Anderson he of Mortal Kombat Fame as
well the film stars Lawrence Fishburne
Julie Richardson Kathleen Quinlan and
Sam Neal and it's about a spaceship that
uh well it's a whole lot it's a whole
lot going on we had a ship we're trying
to recover it there's some spooky things
going on it's a spooky season that's why
we're talking about this movie in
addition to its anniversary is it gonna
introduce us to a new Wormhole are we
gonna lose lose our lives we don't know
and that's the fun of Event Horizon it
was not necessarily a hit when it was
released in theater sort of a rushed job
and we'll get into that when we
introduce our guest but the movie has
developed a cult following since then
picked up a lot of Home media sales in
various formats and now we still
reference it way more than you might
actually think even though it's 31
rotten can you believe it 31 rotten it
is fresh with the audience it is 61 with
the audience score and it is featured in
the book Rotten Tomatoes is wrong but
are they really wrong that's why we have
one of our returning favorites here we
talked to her not too long ago for
Batman Returns and she had some very
interesting insights into that film
Justice for Selena Kyle she is back she
is presenter and podcaster to the stars
from the other side of the pond for now
but her adventures have taken her all
across the world time and time again
maybe even to the Stars maybe even
through a black hole let's ask her it's
it's Claire limb we Claire welcome back
to Rotten Tomatoes is wrong hello there
was actually not being to black hole but
I've been to California uh okay close
enough here and uh now I'm in my happy
space again so it's nice to be back
thank you I I love looking at your happy
space you're 100 authentic background we
did check it and um it's it's so fun
because talking to you I was actually in
Vegas when we did the Batman Returns
episode so now we're both at our
respective homesteads and I have a
question to ask you
um obviously that we ask all of our
guests when we introduce a movie on here
about Event Horizon but before we get to
that I'm just going to let you know and
I just want to sort of get your gauge on
how bad of a film go where I am I had
never made it all the way through Event
Horizon until this week in prepping for
this show Claire I remember it coming
out I remember renting it I remember
trying to watch it and not hating it but
just for some reason I fell asleep
within an hour is the problem me is that
just the perfect time of the movie to
take a quick nappy poo what is it about
Event Horizon that made me want to fall
asleep why are you napping through Event
Horizon I don't know what's wrong with
me it's definitely you you're the
problem you're the problem Mark uh if
you're napping through a film like Event
Horizon then you need to take a long
hard look at yourself quite frankly uh
well I mean that's what we're here to do
today this is going to be not just an
examination of the movie but a
psychological profile of Mark and Claire
and where we stand so Claire you heard
the Tomato Meter number I have a feeling
I know which way you're leaning on this
one 31 rotten on the Tomato Meter is
Event Horizon is Rotten Tomatoes wrong
about the movie
well it's disgusting what a disgusting
school yes so wrong so wrong it should
be way higher in my opinion for sure way
higher for Claire and me after having
seen the movie start to finish I promise
I stayed awake didn't even need caffeine
for it it's a really fun movie it's it's
a ride it is trippy it does a lot of
different things it's very ambitious I
don't know that pulled all those
Ambitions off entirely but that might
not be the fault of the movie so there's
a lot to talk about here with Event
Horizon but before we get into that we
need to know what the critics were
saying at the time of its release in
1997 and why it has that according to
Claire lemon I curiously load Tomato
Meter at 31 so let's turn it over to our
buddy Tim Ryan he's our expert review
curation manager here at Rotten Tomatoes
and he's going to tell us what was going
on back in 97 with all those film
reviewers it's two minutes with Tim Hit
the music
dance with Tim over the last couple
years I've been working on a project
called RT archives in which we go back
and find reviews for classic movies when
they were new like say godfather reviews
from 1972 or Wizard of Oz reviews from
1939 but one particular area of interest
for me has been lost films there is a
staggering number of movies from the
1890s to the early 1930s that were
either forgotten or burned up in a vault
fire or decomposed because early films
were made of Highly unstable materials
you can't see any of these movies today
but you can read reviews of them from
when they came out and you can get an
idea of what they felt like so what does
this have to do with Event Horizon given
that most notable lost films are almost
a century old it's hard to imagine that
anything of recent vintage could go
missing but that's exactly what happened
to large swaths of Paul W S Anderson's
sci-fi horror film upon its release in
theaters Event Horizon was a critical
and Commercial disappointment but it
quickly developed a cult following on
video so there was interest in a
director's cut and almost all the extra
footage was missing what was in it
additional character development in
multiple endings but also extended
scenes of the nightmarish visions that
have made this an underground favorite
for many horror Buffs and the missing
footage is only added to its Sinister
Mystique all this being said the vision
that the public saw back in 1997 was
largely considered stylish but otherwise
derivative
Event Horizon is rotten at 31 on the
Tomato Meter with 86 reviews and it has
a 61 audience score so what did the
critics have to say in a rotten review
Dennis King of the Tulsa World wrote
unfortunately Anderson can't seem to
decide whether he's making a sci-fi
thriller a ghost story a gory horror
film or a metaphysical musing on the
nature of Good and Evil however in a
fresh review Owen gliberman of
Entertainment Weekly wrote just when
you've written off this deep space
nightmare as a late summer melange of
alien Fantastic Voyage The Shining and a
dozen more forgettable other worldly
Thrillers it unleashes some of the most
unsettling horror imagery in years the
Rotten Tomatoes critics consensus reads
despite a strong opening that promises
sci-fi Thrills Event Horizon quickly
devolves into an exercise of style over
substance whose flashy effects and
gratuitous Gore failed to mask its over
Reliance on horror cliches so that's
Event Horizon I hope they don't lose the
three hours of outtakes from this
podcast which are terrifying back to you
folks
that they are Tim outing me I I'm a one
hit wonder and well maybe that's an
outtake I was trying to say it was a one
take Wonder but it's been a long day
here Claire maybe we do need to have a
vault that just stores all of the
Forgotten footage of Rotten Tomatoes is
wrong when you hear that stuff when you
hear all of the things that went on with
this movie afterwards like it how do you
wrap your brand around where's the
footage
this is the thing like it's already I
think we see hints of how disturbing and
gory it it already is it could be so I
I'm very curious about what that looks
like and it's missing I mean there's
nowhere to be seen now but I love that
kind of lore behind films and I guess
that does add to the Mystique and
um you know it's one of those things I
think at the time as well like it it
felt I guess for critics felt rushed
there was a lot of Studio interference
as well the lost footage
um perhaps it felt unfinished for some
but over time I actually think it's a
really amazing and great sort of
Pastiche of horror movies up into that
point up into 1997 of that past 15 20
years so I think looking back on it
feels quite nostalgic to me it does and
it is fun to have conspiracy theories
about where is the missing footage it
doesn't feel like oh no the dog ate my
homework it's like no no we really want
to know what happened to this why is it
gone thank you to him for that setup and
uh we're gonna transition into movie
talk now once we hear those tones
[Music]
yeah 97 it's it doesn't feel like that
long ago but it is a movie celebrating
its 25th anniversary I can't believe
that just happened I mean we were just
celebrating the 30th Anniversary you and
me of Batman Returns and now we're here
we are at 25 years for Event Horizon
does Claire limb remember the first time
she laid eyes on the magic that was this
film yeah I didn't see in the theaters I
saw it quite close to the time and um it
was at home
um it was home video and
um I love sci-fi
um and I grew up with films uh like the
alien franchise things like that and you
know I I really enjoyed things like
Hellraiser when I was younger as well so
I quite like sort of 80s and sort of 90s
Horrors as well hell I mean Hellraiser
it kind of went downhill quite fast
there were so many Hellraiser films but
I really did enjoy that too and we see
elements of this through the film but
when I first when I first watched Event
Horizon I quite liked that it was quite
an hour and a half it's quite succinct
it does what it says on the tin I think
it's disturbing enough so I can't
imagine how disturbing it could have
been but from my young eyes at the time
I felt quite Disturbed
um I really enjoyed and I thought it
married all of my loves of sci-fi horror
into one really great succinct film at
the time so I enjoyed it it made me feel
you know and and I don't feel very often
Mark say that I don't feel often
well the movie did I mean it had a
little bit of competition at the box
office it was coming off of this Indie
Sensation that was the full monty that
had come out I believe a couple days
earlier and then it had copwand which
was like a big sort of you know it was
Stallone going for an Oscar and De
Niro's in there and uh steel the
Shaquille O'Neal movie also opened that
same week but you know back back in the
late 90s it was it was sort of August
was like The Dumping Ground of all the
summer movies it just didn't quite feel
like they had the stuff that it took to
be tent poles and so I was hitting the
theater quite a bit back then I actually
think I worked at a movie theater that
summer and I just never made it to Event
Horizon but I will say this I loved the
trailer for that movie I remember seeing
the trailer being like this looks really
intriguing I was a big Lawrence Fishburn
guy he's always good in everything and
and Paul WS Anderson coming off of a
great theatrical experience for me
Mortal Kombat I'm like yeah I'm all in
with this guy and I just never got
around to seeing the movie but the then
you I finally watched it or I guess I
had rented it and the movie kicks off
and it's so funny I the other movie that
I always fell asleep watching when I was
a little kid was Raiders of the Lost Ark
so it's not a commentary on the quality
of the movie It's just something happens
at a certain time and I'm just I'm just
out like a light but Event Horizon I
always got picked up on the Sci-Fi
aspect of it really quick I never quite
made it to the horror spooky side of it
you could feel the tone right from the
start the way there's more than meets
the eye here but he didn't really know
what was happening with this ship that
itself is a manifestation of a
possession or a demon and the way that
they sort of pitched it was this is The
Shining taking place in outer space and
so do you remember the movie having a
visceral effect on you when you saw it
or was it sort of like an acquired taste
where you knew you liked something about
it but it just didn't really hit you the
first time you watched it no I pretty
much loved it the first time that I saw
because I'm I'm a sucker for these kind
of films and I thought that what really
grabbed me which is what I mentioned a
little bit earlier was some of the
horror references within it you can
you'll recognize some imagery that's
quite close to Hellraiser in the movie
um also for talking about the shading in
space there's like a sort of flood of
and a wave of blood at one point which
is very reminiscent so like the sort of
blood coming of the elevator and the
overlooked Hotel so there's like little
moments for me that sort of hit you know
the hit sort of in a sort of horror fan
sort of way I loved it but and I even
loved the set design at the time I
thought the set design was great
um it was based on uh the Notre Dame
Cathedral that's amazing like that the
ship was based on the cathedral in Notre
Dame uh what how incredible so it's very
iconic to me because when I think of
Event Horizon even though I can see the
ship I can see that round spiky orb
surrounded by water I can see the blood
I can see the death and I can see the
kind of horrible gory scenes and that's
why it hit quite hard for me and that's
what horror does best it impacts you
quite deeply and that imagery stays with
you for years I mean 25 years you see
Event Horizon I can see Samuel's
bloodied face and eyeballs you know all
of these things are incredible it's an
incredible film it is and it does what
great horror movies do even you know you
hear some of the critics lambaste it by
saying it doesn't know what it wants to
be it doesn't want to be a horror movie
a Sci-Fi all these things and I'm like
it can be more than one thing it doesn't
have to neatly fit into a section of
Blockbuster Video and even though I had
nodded off by the time like the real
scary elements of this movie sort of are
pushed to the Forefront you just felt
something was a little off but I just
love that premise of you have this ship
that was ahead of its time that
disappeared and now it's reappeared and
we got to go investigate it and see what
happened I mean that is the exact way to
set up a movie like even like The
Haunting in outer space where we're
basically going to the house that your
parents told you do not go to that house
it's on the edge of town it's at the end
of the street it's really creepy the
lawn hasn't been maintained you do not
want to go in that house but there's
just something so intriguing that you
can't say no and if you're a person of
science like astronauts are Claire this
is everything that they've ever wanted
it's like you just science is The Quest
For answers and so what better answer to
get then where the hell has this ship
been for the last decades yeah exactly
and before I go on with my next point so
actually I'd like to start calling you
sleepy Alice if that's okay with you uh
sleepy Alice says no your new name we're
gonna have to change that for all right
into my old podcast Brian Brian
not the first woman to uh to pick up on
that trust me
TMI TMI Mark TMI you're not pantsing
yourself in the greatest light here I
have to say about my naps
um I think well as as nonsense the the
some of the critics said rather is is
nonsense because you can combine sci-fi
and horror and you can also combine
sci-fi and religious themes this ship we
don't know where it's been it's clear as
the film goes on that has been to Hell
and back you know and I love that
element of combining and this is what
good sci-fi horror does
um and start horror and sci-fi does
you're in space you're in the cold dark
dead of space but also you're facing
your inner demons all of the crew are
facing their inner demons and those
fears are manifesting themselves in
front of them and on the ship it's about
religion in a reflection God hell the
cold dead of space that is more scary to
me facing my inner demons and space than
being chased by an alien you know I mean
if you had to face urine inner demons in
space mark what would they be what would
your inner demons be my inner demon is
just the lack of a pillow it's like I
keep trying to put my head down then the
pillow just keeps moving just so I can't
quite get a good night's rest and you're
going it's uncomfortable and it isn't it
it's very uncomfortable
but but we had had you know Haunted
House movies since really or haunted
house stories I should say even before
movies were an art form and then you
know Stephen King comes along we get a
haunted car with Christine we get a
haunted hotel with the shining and I
just know I'm sure there's like you know
I'm sure one of the pumpkin head movies
has a haunted tractor or something in it
but
um and I do want to give a shout out to
our expert researcher for this show and
for my Show versus Mark Hoffmeyer has an
article on rottentomatoes.com that where
it's like the five things that you know
really he appreciates about Event
Horizon and and why it still is
um such a a thrilling movie that holds
up 25 years later and one of the points
that he makes in it is that you have the
horror film influence just like what you
said with Hellraiser and sort of the
look of the ship and and it also reminds
me of 2001 A Space Odyssey just because
that movie is more horror-weaning than I
think it gets credit for because it's
obviously a Sci-Fi Masterpiece directed
by uh the same guy who did The Shining a
little bit later but you also have this
ship and this computer that becomes
sentient and starts to have you know
feelings and like wants to take over and
you feel that creep in with this ship as
well and you just wonder where the hell
it's been what what what possessed it
what got in it it let me ask you this
with the character of Dr Weir who's
played by Sam Neal what were his
intentions initially do you feel like he
always had some devious like you know
weaning differently than just a man of
science should or do you think that he
was at one time pure hearted with this
endeavor and then it just broke really
bad and he couldn't get him self out of
it I thank the doctor we're a character
is very very interesting he's very
complex character as we start to see his
story unfold he's a man of science
clearly he's driven for the Curiosity
that Curiosity that needs to discover
you know and clearly he wants to
understand where the ship's been I don't
think his intentions
are nefarious at the start but as his
inner demons take over and obviously the
ship is a character in itself as you
sort of are mentioning you know
Christine you know the car is a
character The Overlook Hotel you know as
a character in itself you know and The
Shining so that's why this is this
really works this ship is it also a
character this [ __ ] takes hold of Dr
Weir and I see and you see start to see
his story unfold and I think that his
sadness and fear turns to anger and pain
which what it always does with human
beings you know anger and fear comes
from sort of sadness and insecurity and
so as a shame somewhere along the lane
that gets lost so I think he's quite a
complex character he's not just an evil
villain he's someone with a very tragic
past someone who was driven by curiosity
and then taken over by pain you know and
that's the sad thing about him actually
but the beauty of casting Sam Neal in
this role is that everybody on Earth was
now conditioned to trust this guy
particularly as a scientist because
Jurassic Park had come out four years
earlier and I mean you know again
Samuel's a wonderful actor he's been in
a lot of memorable roles but we're
seeing Dr Alan Grant basically just
transfer his knowledge of dinosaurs to
spaceships and to the construct and how
to how to restore them how to save them
and so we just inherently are ready to
follow this guy wherever he's going and
part of that is just you get lucky with
the casting but you got to wonder if
that's in the back of Paul WS Anderson's
mind when like you're guessing this
movie it's like who's the scientist that
everybody trusts now it's the guy from
Jurassic Park I mean it's you could not
have casted that film better and then to
have just a a matter of fact leader we
have a job to do let's get this Mission
done I think that Lawrence Fishburne was
another stroke of Genius when it comes
to just casting the perfect Miller role
absolutely and you know before like I'd
love to see a Jurassic Park Event
Horizon crossover we're like imagine the
T-Rex is facing their inner demons just
like T-Rexes like facing their inner
demons and some Neil just go to the
doctor we were character going crazy
um but yeah like I think that Lawrence
Fishburne does a really great job as
Captain Miller in this film like a
really really great job the thing is
that works really well about the film is
the characters are actually all quite
likable okay Doctor we are Sam Neil okay
he's he's the evil one but actually
quite tragic but there's a part of the
film where Lawrence Fishburne's
character Captain Miller says he sees
the footage here's the footage he goes
right we're getting out here you know
he's not waiting around he's like no
I've got to get you all to safety it's
not like other films where it's like
let's investigate further and maybe
crawl through this duct and just hide
for a bit till something happens you
know he's like let's get the heck out of
here and they're all very likable
characters you know you want them to
survive you know and there's that
familial bond that they have at the
beginning which is unraveling as the
inner demons come out and as the movie
goes on and the ship takes hold but
you're still fighting for them you know
and that's what makes them so great with
Lawrence Fishburne obviously at the head
of that he does a great job he's
brilliant even uh Jason Isaacs as the
medic he play he plays DJ the the doctor
on board but Jason Isaacs a few years
later we wouldn't trust him at all
because he's the guy who was just so
ruthless in the movie The Patriot which
he still reminds us on uh every fourth
of July on Twitter which is hysterical
but Jason Isaacs is great in this movie
Julie Richardson Kathleen Quinlan as we
mentioned the cast is Top Notch and then
when you actually dive into the story
I'm curious from your perspective Claire
because you saw this relatively early I
would say in its lineage even though you
didn't see it in the theater most other
people didn't see in the theater too it
was a 60 million dollar production
budget it only made a little over 40 in
theaters and so most folks came to it I
think relatively quickly once it hit
home video home baby D DivX was around
that time if that's the way you broke
but what do you think made this movie
beget such a cult following the way that
it did I mean Jane Foster even
references it in thorough love and
thunder in this past summer so it's like
this movie clearly has legs and and even
if people haven't seen the movie or
steeped in the war they know the concept
and they know the movie and that's
thanks to this cult following how did
that start
I think for a star uh horror fans true
horror fans love their horror you know
and they're willing to forgive a lot
okay there is a lot wrong with this
movie if we can think that it feels
perhaps slightly unfinished it's a bit
choppy in places but I think it does
enough and it works well in the hour and
a half that it's been given you know and
we can forgive that the Lord but I think
horror fans especially at that time you
imagine going to like a sort of video
store and you're like you know looking
for like a a video to look watch I used
to love that and then looking at reading
in the back and looking at the front
cover uh without having seen the trailer
because I never saw a trailer I just got
on video and then I started watching it
but I think what's made it really
successful are those references is the
fact that horror fans love their horror
I think that the performances are
absolutely brilliant and there are key
set pieces in the film that really
really work the deaths really work it
feels very climactic each death feels
very very powerful very very tragic so
there's a lot there underneath maybe the
I guess the sort of missing footage and
all of these kind of things that you can
like pick apart there's a lot there that
gives it a lot of strength actually it's
quite a solid movie when you strip all
of that apart so you know goodness only
knows what it would look like if it was
given it's you know all of its footage
and and sort of releasing its full pump
if you know what I mean yeah the film
was originally a 130 minute cut and then
that was edited down by the studio
demanded it to be much trimmer and so it
went all the way down to 96 minutes and
then we're just kind of wondering where
the rest of that footage I think some
people have reported that it's it's it
the only remaining footage it's still in
existence anywhere is on some VHS that's
like in South America or like Brazil
somewhere and we're not really sure if
it's been corroded or not so I I highly
doubt we're ever going to see more from
that shooting of Event Horizon anyway
but and the the editing was rushed
anyway because here's just this weird
nugget about this movies that you may
remember another film that came out in
97 around the holidays that was is sort
of popular Titanic it uh took a long
time to make took a lot of money to make
and it was delayed and so Titanic was
originally slated to come out that
summer but then when Titanic had to be
pushed Paramount was like hey uh we need
this movie to be done now because they
needed something to come out in the
summer and so Event Horizon was tapped
so they had a 10 usually a film is going
to be about 10 to 12 weeks to edit it
they had six weeks to edit this and you
still do all the testing and all the
screenings and all that stuff you got to
do and so you just really didn't have
time to sink your teeth into this and
and Claire when you watch the movie it's
not something as cut and dry as even as
Titanic is I know there's a lot of
characters in Titanic but it's a pretty
simple Love Story there's a whole lot of
stuff going on in Event Horizon we're
getting into the metaphysical realm
we're talking about wormholes horror
Science Fiction it's so much to chew on
and you really want the filmmakers and
the editors be able to take their time
I'm crafting this piece there's still
moments though from this film that just
stand out what is one of those moments
for you what is the scene that you say
that is why this movie still has legs 25
years on
my sleeve as well so okay I'll give you
a couple Okay so
I would say that first of all what
really kind of got me going oh
this film is is really something was
when they find the footage of the the
last crew and you don't really see very
much it's a fuzzy it's kind of fuzzy
footage but you hear the screams it's
like a hell on the ship hell's been
Unleashed on that ship and it's sort of
sexual and gory and crazy and you only
see flashes here and there of of what
you think you might see things going in
people's modes it's horrible it's really
disgusting but I loved it like I like
messed up stuff mark That's what I like
I like the messed up stuff so I kind of
like the messed upness and it kind of
like it's a hint of it and it gives it a
bit of an edge for me
exactly
[Applause]
we're leaving I mentioned how much I
appreciate Lawrence Fishburne as an
actor and and in this role where he's
able to sort of be like a player coach
where he's the leader but he's also the
one that's going to call the shots and
he has to do it sometimes at a moment's
notice you talk about the scene where
they're watching footage of the previous
crew and It's haunting and it's like
what the hell is going on I love as soon
as that video ends this is not gonna
play out like those families that we
yell out that move into a haunted house
at the beginning of the movie we're like
just leave you can find other property
you got plenty of money you don't need
this to be your dumb writer's Retreat
Laurence Fishburne's like okay we're out
of here like as soon as that footage
ends he's like uh not the mission I
signed up for let's get the hell out of
here and so they're not necessarily
Bound by ego to the rest of this Mission
they're not even Bound by like loyalty
to the job they're just like oh crap we
want to leave trust me we just want to
go home and hug our families we can't we
cannot get out and that to me in in the
audience watching it adds so much much
fear to the fact that you want to leave
and now it's become sort of an escape
room situation where you're sort of
forced to do combat against whatever the
hell this ship is presenting at you
because you have the desire to go you
just don't have the means well this is
the thing like that's realistic okay if
you and I want that [ __ ] if I feel like
no I'm gonna
which is
full and looks much better but it's
unrealistic Prometheus so Prometheus
looks amazing Ridley Scott was so
excited so in the cinema but there are
so many holes that you can pick apart
for example
the scientists one of the scientists and
there's a scene in the film where a
little creature comes up and they go
there's a snake-like creature and he he
puts his his face into it it's almost
like he's going good little creature
hello there and of course he dies and
quite rightly so and life choice is
quite frankly did not feel sorry for him
at all yeah do that you don't do that to
a species you never met and you don't
sorry Prometheus you don't have sex in
space okay I don't care how attracted
you are wait until you're back on Earth
just keep it in your pants it's not that
long a journey all right
everyone it's just relax and grab a sock
anyway look it's absolutely fine so yeah
it's things like that where I just think
come on you know there's no urgency in
Prometheus and Event Horizon it's they
start there's a scene where you can see
that familial Bond of the crew starting
to break down because they're starting
to exchange stories of what they've seen
you know I saw this on the ship well I
saw this they're breaking down a little
bit you know they kind of want to leave
at that point but they're not too sure
so you can see them starting to break
down fast because you would you're in
space you're seeing crazy weird stuff
you know and then you hear some crazy
things see the footage I'd be out of
there I mean I would have been out of
there after the first Vision I would be
like in a space pod I'm enjoying okay
bye everyone bye Mark bye sleepy Alice
have a nice nap see you later bye oh
yeah I'm already conked out by that
point it if I hear we want to leave but
we can I'm like well I guess I'll find a
good place to Hole up and snooze until
the rest of the crew figures this out I
mean you you take you take everything
that you see in this movie and you take
the characters do you have a favorite
kill that you're like or I always send
it to like a gory scene because just the
the makeup effects on who Weir has
turned into at least the body that you
know is weird with sort of the the
random stitching of blood across his
face and it's just it's really this
gross pattern
um but it still looks cool and it still
looks horrifying it's it's a nice mix of
like early CGI but a lot of practical
effects in here too yeah which is why it
looks so it was just why it looks so
good you know I think he looks
absolutely brilliant he looks terrifying
um favorite kill okay like there's a
very obvious one which is the DJ kill
where he starts splayed and hung on
display and that's very obvious because
it's very gory and and it reminds me of
a lot of Horrors I watched growing up as
a kid that I wasn't supposed to watch at
the time you know but I would say this
when I was re-watching it a couple of
days ago
um Peter is which is uh Kathleen
quinlan's character her backstory is
quite tragic you know she lost her son
so we see her son appear and she chases
her son she's trying to like catch him
you know she's taken over because she's
a mother and then all of a sudden and
we're like no it's not your kid we know
it's not your kid come on man wake up
it's like it's so you you know what's
gonna happen you know and then she dies
quite Suddenly by Falling to her death
and she just Slams on the ground there's
no Sloan or anything slam it feels hard
and it's horrible and that kind of cough
at the end and just her son from above
going laughing and then walking away
that's kind of that's quite tragic
creepy and and completely horrible
that's it's just really psychologically
horrible so I'd say that one that's an
evil demon or ship or whatever you want
to call it because like if you die if
you go by Christian mythology and you're
like all right I'm gonna die but now I
get to see all my dead relatives or
whatever it's like she's gonna see her
kid the next life and be like you creep
like you don't even want to see your kid
anymore at that point because what he
just did to you for me I I it's it's not
necessarily the ultimate fate that
because Cooper does get ejected into
space for you know uh a time there and
that is like I don't know why it's like
the greatest fear of mine because highly
unlikely that I'm ever going to get
recruited by NASA to be in outer space
but you see it in the movie Gravity with
George Clooney and I'm sure a bunch of
James Bond villains have met their end
in outer space but just the concept of
being in this suit and just getting
ejected from a ship and just floating
until you die like that really sucks
that feels like a really bad way to go
because you're kind of a hero I mean
you're exploring outer space you're
exploring the cosmos but you can't tell
anybody about it you can't take a selfie
you can't post it on Instagram it's a
rough way rough way to go he's just
waiting to die I think that's it it's
space is so vast and lonely yeah I've
often thought about that as well Mark
like what would I mean it sounds very
unlikely either of us are going to be
recruited and get sent into spaces any
kind of Space Heroes like thank you
goodness you're a big Napper and I've
got no upper body strength so it's
really not going to work for us quite
frankly but yeah I've often thought
about that the face the fear of being
lost in a space where it's so vast that
no one can find you like looking for a
needle in a haystack who's gonna come
for you who's going to see you but I
will say by the same token if like I'm
ejected I'm just floating through space
to meet my eternity and then I'm given
the option hey you can keep doing this
and slowly die or uh do you want to go
back to the ship I'd be like I think
I'll take
look I I don't know what's on the other
side of that black hole or a wormhole
whatever you want to say like you know
we blow up the the ship and we kind of
split it into two at the end I do not
want to go with the other I don't want
to be on either part of the ship because
we should talk about how this movie
wraps up which is such a cool shot that
that I I this is exactly how it went
down when I was watching it this week
again for the first time all the way
through I'm watching it and and by this
point I realized that previous Mark was
wrong for nodding off during this boot
like it just for whatever reason it was
up too late I don't know what it was I'm
here now and I like Event Horizon should
be a fresh movie so you're watching and
at the end the very end we do have some
survivors and it's like okay we got some
hope we got a rescue team here but then
we we pan out a little bit and we see
the ship close right back in and it's
like uh oh we're just gonna relive the
same cycle like is and and I saw that
and I rewounded just to make sure I was
seeing what the movie wanted me to see
that we're just starting this baby all
over again and it's not going to end any
better is there anybody well I'll I'll
back up your take on the ending of this
movie given that it might not have been
the cut that all the filmmakers had
desired to have I think it's a pretty
effective way to close out the story
so it's it's not a happy ending it's an
ominous ending I guess
you kind of can fill in the gaps and I
think the best endings are when you do
fill in the gaps you know I don't think
we need a happy ending and I think
especially with horror and Hell
something as
impending as hell you know like if the
ship has been to Hell and back and that
is such a powerful and crazy hellish
place the power of that overtaking them
how can they get away from that how can
they you know and do they have the
science and the resources to escape
probably not you know we are you know
weak and we're human after all so if
there's something like that then you get
no chances and so I quite like that
ominous ending I like the fact that
there is no sequels there's no talk of
what happens next it just is what it is
and that's how it is and it ends to like
you know sort of techno 90s techno which
is great it's an interesting choice uh
but yeah I I like the ending I think the
ending suits the film for sure I'm gonna
say something that sounds like I'm not
rooting for anybody on that ship but I
just again again I've watched alien a
lot and I'm familiar with the franchise
and this film has clear Inspirations
from the movie Alien from 1979 one of
which is I don't know that I necessarily
want anybody who has experienced any of
the events in the alien movies or
Prometheus or alien Covenant or whatever
to ever come back to earth because I
don't know what they're bringing with
them and that scares the crap out of me
I think the same could be said for these
haunted Souls even if it's all inside
their head I don't know that I want
anybody from Lewis and Clark or the
Event Horizon ever to make it safely
back to Earth because what is
accompanying them Claire where's your
Humanity Mark they're not human anymore
they're gone
sleepy Alice has spoken and he says stay
out of our world
sleepy than dead I'll tell you that much
um would you rather welcome like an
alien though like that was visiting or
or someone like that back so you've seen
me interact with the dog you know if I
saw an alien on Earth I would be just as
dumb as the Prometheus scientist and I
try to give it Reese's Pieces and I
would just try to be friends and and
give it a course or whatever but you
would die and you would die I would
totally eat it and and fine that's that
that's my fate so be it I was I died a
nice guy but if you you you hit on
something that I think a lot of fans
started to debate back and forth about
this movie and that is that so many
times on this show like when we had you
on we talked about Batman Returns we
obviously had many sequels maybe not a
direct sequel to that film but a lot of
other adventures in the Batman Universe
is there a way to go back to Event
Horizon people are still talking about
25 years later is is there a way that we
just say hey that was a great movie it's
a great starting point let's remake it
let's people still clearly have an
appetite for this let's do this thing
right or let's do a sequel or let's do a
prequel and show the initial Voyage of
the Event Horizon I mean there's a lot
to play Within this world I know that we
live in a day in an age where IP is IP
and you gotta have some familiarity and
you want to make a franchise out of
everything should there be any more to
do with Event Horizon I'm gonna say as
much as I would love to I'm going to say
no because a prequel I would I think
would appeal more to me than a sequel
however a prequel would just be us
seeing the ship making its Journey with
a with a bunch of crew that ends up
dying and end up with the same fate as
the crew seems to be too similar almost
and then I think with a sequel
I don't know like I I just kind of think
what we're gonna go back and just find
the ship again I think the story's been
told and even the director himself Paul
Anderson has said I'm very happy with
what I've made I'm very happy with it
and this is what I've made I don't think
we need to always keep going back and
explaining the story over and over again
I don't know I don't think a sequel or a
prequel would work for me I think it is
what it is it's its own film and I think
we should just be happy with what we've
got there's lots of other sci-fi Horrors
out there that we can watch that will
satiate our appetite I'm fine with it
the way it is having said that and and I
I think I agree with you for the most
part for some reason I'm very interested
in a prequel to Event Horizon I don't
know why because we pretty much see the
very truncated version in what a 20
second clip in this movie and you know
we kind of know how it ends but I
if I told you that oh my gosh they
finally discovered all the unused
footage from this movie
you're going to see that opening night
right if they're like no we have the 130
minute cut and it's back we found the
footage and it looks great and this is
the movie we wanted to make I think that
does boffo box office if we live in a
world where that would ever be possible
oh yeah I'm gonna get my brown pants on
I'm gonna get my adult diapers on and
I'm going like I am going Mark yeah 100
because you only see that tiny little
clip who knows what could have come next
so that is the only thing that I'd be
interested in watching at this point I
think that we are in some senses
prequels and sequels do sort of work in
terms of film or TV but I think we're
living in a sort of world where the sort
of the industry is just feeding us more
and more and more like we're gluttonous
for more and more more sometimes I don't
think more is good I think we need to go
on a diet Mark that's what I think we
need to go on a diet well we got a an
event horizon uh the name of a movie in
Event Horizon but it it took place in
like I think it was like one show and it
really had nothing to do with the the
1997 film and you know I think one of
the tragedies of of losing all that
footage is that there's this like
extended version of hell
that that Paul W Sanderson had intended
but and he was even quoted as saying
this is that he the original version had
a bunch of Gordon special effects and
there was a bunch of like pus and
maggots and stuff and it made test
audiences completely shut down so the
test audiences for this movie that you
know some depending on what studio it is
the directors and it never really want
the movie to be tested for anybody and
then the studios need to see if this is
going to put any butts in seats and
apparently the test audiences did not
react well to that more extended deeper
cut going into hell and so maybe it's
for the best because I'm not a huge I
love scary movies I like the more
psychological scares I don't necessarily
need to see everything spelled out on
the screen for me uh hell looks pretty
intense in the event horizon yeah it
does it really does I'd love to I mean
imagine though if we went to see it
together Mark I would be uh counting
down and taking note of when you went
for a fear nap I'm gonna call it a fear
nap yep I think you're body just shut
down knowing what was coming next and I
think that's what was happening not sure
about was it Raiders of the Lost Ark I'm
not sure what happened there with your
fear napping
um I I guess I'm scared of of the most
evil on Earth or in outer space so I was
scared of Nazis and I was scared of
whatever was happening to the event
horizon and I just won Lawrence
Fishburne to make it out of a movie I
don't think that's too much to ask
um we you know it's funny he this is our
our second week in a row talking about
Mr Fishburn he was in night right now
three three the Dream Warriors and uh we
sort of covered the whole memory Elm
Street franchise which does have a lot
of Gore and pus and probably maggots at
some point last week so uh our former
Rotten Tomatoes editor-in-chief the
great Joel Mears uh one time had to had
an exchange with Sam Neal he got to
interview him
um for his film Rams and so he Joel no
and knowing Joel this is totally on
brand for him he asked about Event
Horizon and Sam Neal said that my main
regret with that film is that I thought
it was cut too fast I I love Thrillers I
love the alien Dimension to that you
don't know what's going on there's a
threat but you don't know what it is and
he said I think Paul got a bit board
cutting it and he cut it too fast and
again this is all in the context of they
only had six weeks to cut this movie
anyway so Sam is just saying there
should be a lot of Silence because in
silence in the dark there lies the dread
it doesn't quite breathe enough that
film I'd like to see it re-cut and I
think that particular Niche audience
would enjoy watching it more and I agree
with Sam Neal there's only so much you
can do with that but I think the one
flaw with this movie is that it does try
to throw too many visuals
at us at too quick a clip and I think
that that is a jarring
change up from the first half of this
movie is that it really just starts
throwing the kitchen sink as far as just
gross out stuff and it's warranted given
what the events are I just think that
it's a huge change of pace for this
movie to take
some fans on the ride with it other ones
like me either got sleepy or just were
like I don't really know what this movie
is but I think I can safely get it to
Fresh I think this movie should probably
land around 70 75 percent which because
it's such a fantastic storyline and I
thought given all the backstage drama
going on the fact that this movie came
out at all is a miracle and much less
that it's really good but I don't think
it's a great film if you had to put a
number on the Tomato Meter Claire where
should
Event Horizon B I'm gonna agree with you
I don't think it deserves to be much
past 80 I think somewhere between 75 to
79 would be fine so let's say 78 it's
very good I think they did very well
with the the performances are great I
think the set's great I think the
effects are really good and the story
the back story of the characters so
there's lots of layers there to play
with so it deserves that I don't think
it deserves much more than that but it
should be 78 but now here's the real
burning question before we exit movie
talk
can you watch Titanic and still enjoy it
Claire or every time you put on Titanic
now are you just thinking uh what could
have been if we just fast-tracked that
movie and got it out in the summer then
we could have had Event Horizon in time
for that Year's Christmas maybe the full
version
I'm wondering like oh I'm interviewing
Billy Zane very soon as well which I'm
quite looking forward to that's gonna be
a good buff he could have been great in
about Horizon you know he could have
played he could have played the doctor
he could have played Sam Neal's party
Billy Zane could have been in that movie
I really did that I think Billy Zane
could have been in that movie but can
you imagine Billy Zane as the doctor
we're character he would have been a
very different sort of villain I see I
ain't trusting that guy I love I love me
some Billy Zane I trust Dr Alan Grant I
do not trust Billy Zane as a doctor and
out as soon as I know Billy Zane is like
the one behind the engineers of the show
I'm like wait a minute uh-uh not
trusting you someone left the screwless
no some things like falling apart
there's some steam coming out from the
grates over there we don't know what's
going on and Billy's just like sitting
in the car with a cigar I'm just
enjoying himself yeah I mean a guy
couldn't even get the Titanic to safety
I think he's gonna get the Event Horizon
there um exactly he's been one of the
space pods you know Far Far Away he'd be
like saving his own skin like he's just
like the Titanic but yes I would like to
see I wonder I would watch that a sequel
with Billy Zane there you go I would
watch that that's that's the film we
talk about movies here and occasion we
get genius ideas for their sequels in an
alternate Dimensions so we're not
blaming you Titanic our heart will go on
but poor went out for Event Horizon at
your next screening so that does it for
movie talk this is Claire limp she
always have great ideas for sequels
prequels and some pretty damn good
thoughts on a movie that I know a lot of
people get in their feelings about Event
Horizon 31 percent of the Tomato Meter
but not according to Claire and I were
much more in alignment with his audience
score that is fresh uh Claire you're
always a delight when you're on here uh
we hope to see you on this side of the
pond sooner rather than later uh do you
have any projects you want to tout
coming up anything in the works that you
can tell us social media handles all
that good stuff okay so in terms of
projects there's a lot of things I can't
talk about but um I am at various Comic
Cons
um around the UK up until Christmas and
possibly in America at the beginning of
the year next year I just came back from
Salt Lake which was fun so if you want
to catch up with all of my news
um you can check me on Twitter it's we
clear and on Instagram It's weekly or
here and if you want to catch me
streaming it's we clear here on Twitch
as well we clear that's w-e-e is in a
wee lab that is we clear do you have a
good movie TV recommendation for us it
doesn't have to be in the vein of Event
Horizon but if that's your if that's
your genre sure
um the moment I'm watching the rings of
power no
um I am enjoying it I mean I am enjoying
it but there are moments where it
becomes so like my name is glad rule of
the elves of the hills of Saint Michael
and the wings of the feet of and it's
just it becomes a bit too much I was
actually laughing while eating toast and
drinking tea the other night in my
pajamas going this is great it's like
comedy it's like a great comedy it's
funny you brought that up because I I
put up a poll on Twitter today actually
because I'm just doing a lot of work and
prep for my shows in New York and um so
just so I can do stand up and have fun
so we're kind of banking a lot of stuff
today and I was like look I'm going to
be done with work after this so I'm just
gonna have a little bit of uh liquid
refreshment we'll say and I want to
watch a show I want to start all these
shows I haven't had time to watch yet so
rings of Power House of the dragon and
or those are my three that I put on the
pole or just re-watch the Michael Jordan
documentary again rings of power is the
way Claire goes or should I go house of
the dragon or and or first
I would go rings of power right I'm
getting a lot of wrecks for that I'm
getting a lot of people writing me not
just voting in the poll they're like
writing me and tell me no you're gonna
love rings of power so I guess I'm a
Rings a power guy it's a great comedy I
just really I find it really funny it's
it takes itself so seriously that at one
point you just have to laugh but it's
actually if you're genuinely a Lord of
the Rings fire at the fan I think
they're done really well so I'm I am
enjoying it genuinely for sure all right
then there you have it rings of power
Event Horizon a whole lot of sci-fi
fantasy with a dash of heart pinched in
because it's the seasoned it is once
again you can email us at RT is wrong at
rottentomatoes.com subscribe rate review
whatever your podcast platform of choice
recommends you do for shows you love
make us one of those shows thank you so
much for all of your help for upcoming
stand updates including my special that
is taping live in LA on December 3rd you
can go to mark
ellis.live for tickets and next week
right here on Rotten Tomatoes is wrong
the episode is the best horror movies of
all time the best horror movies of all
time which leprechaun films are gonna
make the cut you gotta tune in next week
for the best horror movies of all time
so for we Claire Claire lamb one of our
favorite Champions here Brian Glenn
producy Lucy Jacqueline Coley the whole
gang at Rotten Tomatoes and at
rottentomatoes.com special shout out to
our buddies Tim Ryan and Mark Hoffmeyer
for this episode I am merely Mark Ellis
and I guess in the words of Miller from
Event Horizon we're leaving
[Music]
thank you
[Music]